hasta el 2015 el exportador de plátano
siempre serio en el mois nunca había
ocupado un cargo político año en el que
a pesar de ser poco conocido por el
público general el haitiano se lanzó
como candidato a la presidencia con el
partido ph teca una opción de centro
derecha el empresario consiguió ganar
las elecciones generales del octubre de
ese año con el 32,8 por ciento de los
votos pero los comicios fueron
invalidados por irregularidades y no fue
hasta febrero de 2017 que chove en el
mois juró el cargo y se convirtió en el
presidente del país más pobre de américa
desde entonces
haití ya se estaba encaminando hacia una
crisis política y social que no le
pondría las cosas fáciles al recién
nombrado mandatario con miles de
personas en las calles desde mediados de
2018 la crisis alcanzó su punto álgido
el 7 de febrero de este año cuando el
dirigente acusó a la oposición de estar
tramando un golpe de estado con el apoyo
de algunos jueces sus desertores
sostenían que su mandato terminaba en
febrero de 2021
no sé en qué este había empezado antes
de jurar el cargo en medio de una época
políticamente convulsa haití enfrenta un
gran problema de seguridad el poder de
las bandas criminales ha aumentado con
la crisis política y los índices de
secuestros y la criminalidad están
disparados por eso muy sin tentó frenar
el descontento social y las protestas
impulsando un referendo para votar una
nueva constitución el próximo 26 de
septiembre y busco apoyos
internacionales como el de eeuu para
permanecer en la presidencia el político
de 53 años terminaba su mandato en
febrero de 2022